So the real tried and true theme of the Trump
[inaudible] and C is manga, except it stands
for making attorneys get attorneys.
And Rudy Giuliani is now starting speculation
that he may be getting ready to turn on Donald
Trump and to tell the whole story as the walls
are closing in on him.
He has now hired three lawyers to defend him
as the Ukraine scandal has pushed Rudy's corruption
into the forefront once again, so listen,
we don't know yet whether Rudy Giuliani is
doing this in preparation to turn on Trump
or not, but it is certainly looking more and
more like that's a real possibility, especially
with multiple of Rudy's own associates getting
themselves arrested, but about to leave the
country on one way.
Tickets to Europe.
Quick reminder.
Former New York city mayor Rudy Giuliani has
been Donald Trump's lawyer for some time now,
but really he's a TV lawyer and I've talked
about this before.
Rudy Giuliani is not Donald Trump's lawyer
in the sense that he's the guy doing the legal
work and filing the motions and trying cases.
He's a lawyer who is really functioning as
a lobbyist and PR man and influence peddler.
He plays Trump's defender on TV.
He plays Trump's defender in the media more
broadly.
He makes connections.
He pedals influence.
That's what he does.
But he has a law degree and at one point was
a working and functioning attorney.
It's not uncommon, by the way, that people
who worked as attorneys are effectively become
lobbyists and influence peddlers, but still
are attorneys in name and that command some
level of respect and credibility.
Now, it turns out that Rudy is up to his eyeballs
in the corruption and sketchiness around the
Ukraine situation.
He's traveling all over the world.
He's pushing all sorts of foreign diplomats
and leaders to smear Joe Biden to investigate
Trump's political opponents.
So who knows what criminal acts Rudy may have
committed or directed committed by others.
So now after two of his associates were arrested
on campaign finance charges and the impeachment
inquiry is heating up with Rudy Giuliani is
one of the main people that investigators
will want to talk to.
Rudy has hired numerous attorneys, uh, three
according to a bunch of different reports
about what's going on here.
Now, it's important to understand that Rudy
Giuliani is a Trudell T a total Trump offense.
But in the end, I believe Rudy Giuliani is
not someone with undying loyalty to Donald
Trump.
In fact, it seems most people at some point,
their loyalty to Donald Trump runs out.
Rudy's name was mentioned 68 times during
bill Taylor's recent testimony about the Ukraine
fiasco under oath.
Rudy has been making it more and more clear
that he will continue making unhinged and
outrageous claims about Donald Trump's involvement
with Ukraine.
Each claim less believable than the last,
and I don't think it's unreasonable that if,
and when it gets right down to it, Rudy will
sing for the purposes of self preservation.
This is not some random staffer who was a
coffee boy.
This is also not some random staffer who was
not a coffee boy, but Trump can claim was
just a coffee boy.
There are certain people who have the goods
on Trump.
If anyone does, Rudy Giuliani would be very,
very high on that list.
Now, there's another element to this.
Rudy may not deliberately turn on Trump, but
he might inadvertently implicate Trump or
implicate himself in crimes because he's done
this before.
On Twitter.
I want a K. w there's others more recent,
but I remember when Rudy was being interviewed,
I believe it was by Sean Hannity before it
had publicly been admitted, that the hush
money given to stormy Daniels, even though
it came from Michael Cohen, it really was
Trump who, who did that, right?
It was Trump's payment.
He paid through Michael Cohen before they
publicly admitted it, a Rudy Giuliani went
on and blurted out that actually that is what
happened.
It turns out that wasn't public yet, even
though any reasonable and reasonable person
of course believed that that was the case.
But Rudy sometimes can't help himself.
So this could be a very interesting couple
of months for Rudy Giuliani.
We will of course be watching it, and my question
to you is, if you had to predict it today,
where will Rudy be in two months?
Will he be, will he have turned state's witness?
Will he have become a, not maybe state as
the wrong term here, but will he become someone
who is a witness in favor of Trump's impeachment
for the house of representatives?
Will he simply have faded away as he did for
about a six month period after bundling a
bunch of television appearances in the lead
up to the release of the Mueller report.
Where do you think Rudy will be two months
from now?
What will we know about Rudy Giuliani in two
months?
Let me know by if you're watching on YouTube,
leave a comment down below.
Otherwise, send me a tweet at di Pacman on
Twitter.